what is space-time you already know you
have never met someone at a place unless
it was also at a time you have never met
someone at a time unless Aloka I guess I
get so eat well well wait a minute what
happens to a photon from 13 billion
point 800 million years that comes this
way and enters my eye so I can see it
why where is this worth spacing involved
in that um
it entered your eye at a time and at a
place right here
that's all that that's all this all of
that is all that's all we're not well
once you have formalized space and time
and know that they're conjoined then you
can make all kinds of fascinating
calculations well Rosa let the trains
going and I'm out of there I'm walking
down the train I'm walking on there at
the time and the training is James what
is all that's all the consequences of
thinking about space and time as
conjoined but it's confusing
oh I will not only is it the universe is
under no obligation to make sense to
William Shatner no but William Shatner's
under the obligation to make sense of
the universe as is you are doing and and
and and and why do why do I slow down as
I approach the speed of light it doesn't
apply to a photo thinking now you want
to freak out I don't you know I don't
your head to explode
you ready yeah okay no you're not ready
you real I'm ready I'm ready okay the
faster you go the slower time ticks say
that again the faster you move yeah
slower at times you have said for you
yeah as seen by others right as you
approach the speed of light time
continues to slow down yes at the speed
of light time stops which means for a
photon moving at the speed of light when
it is absorbed in your retina it is the
same instant it was emitted at the Big
Bang fourteen billion years ago that's
what I thought that's the filter gets
emitted BAM it's in your as far as its
concerned it is in your eye in that same
and we measure that photon and and these
are
the big bad I know that that came from
the Big Bang and I'm watching it and
it's taken 13.8 billion years to reach
you but if you are that photon it does
not experience that time delay what a
great science fiction story that
instantaneous
[Applause]
[Music]
you